so there's my equation okay I could use
that to find right when am I gonna hear
a hundred thousand okay so it's a simple
substitution okay a hundred thousand is
a population so I'll say one hundred
thousand is equal to five thousand yes
okay and I'm just solving for T because
it's a question oh and what time do I
get so dividing through by five thousand
what are yet we get twenty okay convert
it to a log equation again so this index
up here is going to become the subject
and this is just gonna be a lot twenty
all right so now I just rearranged a
little bit
I remember I told you to affect your
calculators as you leave these out a lot
be careful your brackets as you put this
yeah and let's get to the nearest minute
shall we yeah yeah
so I'll just just for the sake of it
just to make sure you know you have
exactly the right number I'll put down
my calculator so yeah if we wait to the
nearest minute
it'll be 65 okay now don't forget these
are all going to be problem solving type
questions okay so don't be content
except you question one which is
literally asking for an equation here I
don't want to finish on an equation okay
so I want to conclude that so I would
say the population reaches 100,000 after
65 minutes
I'll leave that there
I think this will probably innovation so
does anyone perform your mother's they
don't have any question about Howard
about that you can see this early
Germanic right it's just okay just
impact is just equations really you
substituting stuffing in solving okay if
it really does depend on the wedding
doesn't it so I think the way I went the
question was how long does it take to
get to 100,000 and again actually maybe
even more certain them with money right
populations are indivisible but you
can't have I don't know I didn't study
biology you have halfback sure
anyway what to get there okay so yeah
okay let's keep going
so now I'm gonna look at the rate of
change okay so the rate of change is de
piel de tape right so if I'm going to
work out either of these I'm gonna need
to know what to give it to you
now I'm very conveniently at the last
line of my working here the question why
okay so that P what's de piel de ticket
of it
yeah it's we actually define this
earlier right it's just this x the cave
that we had before and of course it
makes sense that it would be the K
because it's just channeled on an
exponential function so there's the K is
the derivative of the inside function so
therefore you can write it like this
okay and I suppose you could simplify
this 5000 on 30 sometimes because you
can see this it's such an awkward way to
write it
sometimes people would just leave it as
K and they'll say else out here you know
K is equal to you know specify its value
okay and then thereafter as a righty
equations like dupioni T they'll just
leave it as K okay or deliver as a
decimal approximation okay doesn't
really matter as long as you've
specified it somewhere here or in the
equation now what we're asking for two
things no one after one hour okay so
it's up to T and then when there are
50,000 bucks here so we do the
wintertime
since this gives us the value of T okay
we are we can actually just take T equal
60 and some it's trading because that's
what this is in terms of right so let's
do that
when t equals
now by the way as I almost did
oh yeah um you could simplify that to
two right off right you could do that
it's probably a bad idea because you
always want to not just present an
answer so that the marker can read it
but you also want to make it easy for
you yourself to go to come back and work
out okay did I do this right or not okay
so seeing this you for that okay I can
see exactly what I'm doing the next line
when I simplify you know suppose you
guys know one two pressure we do this
kind of thing right we say 60 divided by
30 is 20 or three or something else
similar right but if it's not written
down you look at that line you'll say it
looks fine
okay and you won't see that okay this
clearly doesn't equal that which is the
next line I'm gonna have okay so what am
I going here
okay now by the way at this point I
couldn't I couldn't cram that into the
calculator it would work oh but we can
do a little better than that right I
mean we generally try and avoid pretty
complicated expressions into our
calculator because number one it takes a
long time number two if you get it wrong
the calculator won't tell you it would
just give you the wrong answer in smoke
at you right so how can we and we do a
little better with this what ways can we
slow simplify that a little war what
could you do yeah okay so that's the
first thing okay now how does this
improve things good right so e to the
log X right by definition that's just
going to be X right just like you can
reverse as well that's what invest
functions do right log of M DX is also
just X okay this part here is just 16
that's about as good so pop that into
kappa what do you get what's out right
what you get and we're gonna daddy let's
just do to the nearest bacteria well we
got great okay so uh I'll put the
calculator out put just see you
okay now by the way I did this here and
I did it over there as well it's a minor
thing really but when you're solving
these equations you know this quantity
here and this derivative there unitless
and they don't have any given associated
with them but you've just got an
equation okay so that's why I put near
here I'm gonna supply the unit when I
make my conclusion okay
so here was 65 minutes this is not a
quantity but a rate okay so I can say
after one hour the population is
increasing of course you could take the
increasing if you like if that if the
question was alright so happy that so
far no sorry that was a question are you
happy with that so far
welcome to you any good last question
what's different
well the variable they're giving us
right that we have to solve is 50 that's
material and I still want a rate of
change now you're ready to change up
here right is in terms of time okay so
this shouldn't be the equation that I
use so what should I do instead well
what sort of ways could you go that's
all yeah okay good we could sort of do
this question okay we could say okay
well when are there 50 thousand bacteria
find that value for T and then do this
subbing in and you'll get a value out at
the end they'll totally give you the
right answer but it'll take about three
times longer than the method we should
use because these are a special kind of
question right what other way could we
do
right good go back to your very first
line of working okay
we said this is um it's puppet we said
DP on DT this is the whole thing about
expected exponential growth or decay
right he is K P okay so the sweet thing
about working with Exponential's is you
can know what the growth rate is if you
know what the population is you know
okay there's a population of this many
will they ought to be going at about
this amount if you know what your K
that's your AR okay so therefore let's
bring in our value of K which is 1 on 30
involve four that's K and then you take
your population which is 15,000 okay and
that allows you
well how'd you get to three okay and
then of course you do the same thing
okay
so you've got
so as you finish writing that I guess I
would kind of compare what we just did
to you know when you're first learning
calculus and derivatives are the rules
of differentiation right and you see
something like you know differentiate
this something like that right and
because you've just learnt it you're
like that's a question I'll use question
rule and then you twist yourself in
knots and you take you know much longer
you might get the right answer if you're
in excluded okay but up you're just as
likely to get a role or just to take
forever
so remember exponential growth in decay
the whole point is that you can notice
things about the growth rate without
necessarily knowing the expression in
fact if we'd said you know this hadn't
set up all of that okay all you need to
know is the the K that constant of
proportionality and then that feeds into
whatever your population will be you get
them read out okay
increasing at